yesterday President Trump hosted a
celebration of our country at the White
House and the moment everyone's talking
about today is when Trump joined the US
Army chorus to sing god bless america a
lot of people noticed Trump didn't know
the words to the song
check out this clip of the president
singing god bless america
[Music]
he kind of goes to when he's doing that
you know problem
well apparently Trump Trump was very
unhappy with the criticism that he got
for not seeming to know the song he
insists he was singing the song
perfectly today the White House doubled
down
they released a full album of Trump
singing other classic patriotic songs a
full album check it out the White House
presents songs of a patriot President
Donald J Trump sings American classics
like my country tis of be my country
America the Beautiful Oh beautiful four
station guys
[Music]
for the song and the rocket man's glare
not thirsty
good
the flag like flies
and the spiritual classic amazing grace
sister Christian
and you know that you're the only one to
say
Amazing Grace plus many more gandalf lat
proud mama american ankles away
BattleBots of the republican stars and
Streisand's rip that one by Bruce
Springsteen The Dukes of Hazzard theme
song grandma got run over by the
Nationwide Insurance agenda and Wang
dang sweet simple songs of a PG
available wherever truck nuts are sold
[Music]
[Applause]
you